In the last movie we talked about data science
without actually having Big Data.
In this movie, we’ll take the compliment
of that.
We’ll look at scenarios in which a person
works with Big Data, but doesn’t require
the full data science skill set.
As a way of reminding ourselves, Big Data
usually involves unusual volume, and velocity,
and variety in the data.
Data Science also has this little diagram.
It involves statistical skills, and domain
knowledge, and coding ability.
And the three of them together gets data science.
Now let’s take a look at, can you do Big
Data with just two of the data science skills?
How about with just statistics and with coding?
The answer of course is yes.
Because that’s where we have machine learning.
Machine learning is a very important area
of data science and this is where a computer
program learns to adapt to new information
as it comes in.
The two most familiar examples are spam filters,
where the computer program learns that a particular
kind of email is spam or not, based on your
own individual responses, and based on the
responses of millions of other people who
use the same email program.
Or, facial recognition and photographs, where
your computer program learns what face belongs
to whom.
Here is an article from Nature that talks
about artificial intelligence and machine
learning in general.
If we scroll down a little bit, it talks specifically
about the problem of facial recognition and
how the computers can learn to identify face.
It is something that is very easy for humans
to do, but much harder for a computer.
So machine learning is a good example of working
with Big Data because it can have volume,
velocity, and variety, but you don’t necessarily
need to have domain knowledge, because the
computer is working without any knowledge
whatsoever.
Another possibility is what Drew Conway, who
created this Venn Diagram, originally called
the Data Zone, that’s the combination of
coding, and domain knowledge without statistics.
Now he says, “danger” here, but there
are some very good examples of data science
here that do not involve statistical knowledge.
The most common of which are word counts and
just parsing of natural language.
The most common tool used for this is what’s
called, the natural language tool kit.
This is a package that’s used in Python,
the programming language.
And it will ask people to do all sorts of
amazing things.
You can do things like word counts.
The best known word count was the one that
was used actually a few decades ago to identify
authorship of the Federalist letters in American
historical political science, all the way
up to the things like, comparing vocabulary
sizes of various Hip-Hop singers.
And so, there’s amazing things that can
be done with natural language by simply counting
how often the words occur, without requiring
any statistical knowledge per se, because
there’s no influential procedure that goes
into it.
And now those are two of the combinations
of data science skills that we have two at
a time without Big Data.
That leaves a third one here, and that’s
statistics and substantive or domain expertise.
And this is traditional research.
Unfortunately, without the coding skills,
you’re not going to be able to deal with
the volume, the velocity, or the variety of
data that characterizes Big Data.
Tremendous things are accomplished in traditional
research, but Big Data is not one of them.
In summary, as far as you have at least two
of the items in the Venn diagram, you can
work with big data.
You can not work with Big Data if you have
just statistical knowledge, or just coding
skills, or just domain knowledge.
Instead, what you would have to do in that
situation is collaborate with people who have
that information and skills.
In fact, collaboration really is the rule
in data science, Because there is such a broad
range of skills that are necessary, nobody
is usually able to bring all of to it, but
they have to work together.
That actually is one of the wonderful things
because I think that most of the interesting
developments come about through collaboration.
And that is something that data science encourages
strongly.
And so, when you look at the relationship
between data science and Big Data, the situation
isn’t exactly even.
It’s possible to do data science with an
incomplete version of Big Data, but it’s
much more difficult to do Big Data work without
the triumvirate of data science skills.